c'est un tout jeune serpent que raymond
a capturé juste à quelques mètres d'ici
sur l'habitation le chalet à
saint-joseph passagers les plus gros
raymond surnommé saipan est un chasseur
de serpents plus précisément un chasseur
de trigone aussi fall espèce venimeuse
endémique de la martinique est
particulièrement dangereuse pour l'homme
détenu par dessus la tap
le reptile passionne cet amoureux de la
nature depuis l'âge de 15 ans raymond
c'est comment traquer la bête comment la
capture et ils recensent à présent c'est
connaît son comportement qu'il étudie
minutieusement depuis des années les
pêcheurs ont levé du bon pied dessus je
tenais et puis depuis je capture quel
que soit l'endroit j'ai pas peur mais
fred boivin raymond est devenu une
référence dans le domaine on l'appelle
un peu partout en martinique pour
capturer le prix gauss et fall dans les
campagnes près des rivières des champs
mais aussi aux abords des maisons
il nous confirme avoir constaté ces
dernières années une recrudescence de
serpent aux endroits fréquentés par
mohamed n'a presque pas manger mais où
toutes les maisons la diva ya un peu de
tout alors les bêtes du sang pour se
chamailler
s'il est dans le bois et pully descend
là viendra tableaux dessins et des 5
décembre puis fermé il descend il faut
des petits
et puis enfin sur les réseaux sociaux
les photos et vidéos de serpents prises
par des habitants sont de plus en plus
nombreuses
le chu de martinique a constaté ces
derniers jours une augmentation du
nombre de patients admis pour des
morsures de serpent